and of course the big story today a lot
for us to focus on a lot for us to read
the uk government has released an
avalanche of documents strategies
consultations research all based around
the drive to reach its target of net
zero emissions by 2050. so mike to you
first of all a huge amount to digest but
what's your instinct are the policies
and the investment there for us to reach
net zero on time
i think overall i feel i feel a bit sad
about it because um it does have a lot
of you know um
good things in there they're just not
scaled up to the point that we need them
i think
um
just to give them a sense of perspective
on the scale i think i added up
something like two and a half million
pounds a year's worth of government
spending which is like um well defense
spending is maybe 20 times that size and
we're talking about 27 billion pounds
worth of spending um on new road
infrastructure so it just hasn't got the
perspective right for a climate
emergency which is kind of such a shame
um in the run-up to the cop when
everyone's looking at us to to see
whether we're
how coherent and serious we really are
but mike isn't the hope that there'll be
lots of private investment that will
come in
yeah and maybe that will
maybe that will help us but if i look at
the scale of
uh of what's being
um what's being trumpeted here you know
i think you know they've under-egged the
new jobs opportunity and if you look for
example at um what they're talking about
for uh heat pumps if you look at the you
know there's there's um you know
some spend on on subsidizing heat pumps
but that that equates to helping about
one household in every thousand
every year to get a heat pump which is
you know that's a small that's a small
pin prick
of a dent in the problem okay and judy
what's your overall thought does this
look like a credible plan to you
i see as a very expensive industry-based
action around technology i do not see as
a formula that can enable people lower
income to participate right now or less
wealthy countries in the world to follow
this formula i mean there's a delay they
talk about cheaper prices to comments on
how long that's going to take is
anyone's guess
and i think that what we really need to
do in the meantime because the delay is
to pay more attention to people-centered
actions that can make a big difference
for example food waste graphically
represented you know as a point of
emission food waste
drawn as a country would be the third
largest country in the world
well yes and let's talk about the cost
to individuals shall we mike because i
know that a recent poll said for example
that the public supports most climate
policies unless there's a personal cost
and you can understand that can't you so
going back to that heat pumps issue
which has been a big kind of attention
grabber in all of this
is there enough
financial support and incentive for
people to switch away from gas boilers
here
there's there's some incentive but but
almost certainly not enough i mean i
think yeah we've touched on on the sort
of the big sadness for the the
opportunity that hasn't yet been taken
here because this whole low carbon
transition plan could be served up in a
way that is financially attractive for
the average household and i think we've
we've just heard the point here that is
really really important and it's all
about putting together a proper coherent
package by which okay something some
really high carbon things in life are
going to get more expensive but overall
there's an opportunity for the average
there should be an opportunity for the
average household to actually be better
off especially if they take some
behavior change
um you know in this low-carbon
transition what's not to like about it
along with the millions of new
low-carbon jobs that we could be having
the government's talking about some of
that but overall it just hasn't got
yet a package that's properly attractive
to everyone in the uk and that's such a
shame because it could be
and of course judy for heat pumps to be
green
we need electricity to come from green
sources we need more of it as well so
what about that switch to make the grid
greener and cleaner does that sound like
a credible plan that's on the table
there
i mean some of it is credible because we
the technology is coming and so on and
we talk about lots of green jobs and if
there's lots of green jobs that's a
great thing but this people dimension
keep coming back to is really important
for example if you look at the gender
dimension which of those jobs they are
actually thinking about appeals to the
female population you know even if you
look at something very simple
gender-based all the power tools are
based on the size and the weight of a
man's hand you know all these things
really matter in images on how the
population participates in this
industrial revolution
that that that's a whole other area that
we could talk about sometime
but perhaps we haven't got the time to
to delve now but
mike what about leadership at cop26 uk a
host is this the kind of plan that boris
johnson can walk in and go look we're
doing this in the uk all you other
countries have to step up
is it enough
well i think my fear is that the
government underestimates just how
smart and discerning a lot of the people
going along to cop26 are going to be
because you know it doesn't i don't
think it takes a rocket scientist to be
able to look at this strategy and see
that it's not it's not really enough
and it could be much better and it
doesn't quite have the coherence that we
could be seeing so you know i'm sad
about that because i think you know that
the most of the attendees uh the cop
will understand that this isn't really a
proper serious strategy that is fully
um
uh
fully aligned with the scale of the
challenge that we face and it's a shame
because the opportunity to actually
rearrange the uk economy a bit and steer
it in a way that it absolutely can uh
you know can be leading it's such an
opportunity it's even such a huge
economic opportunity as well if we were
to push the button really hard
on all the new technologies we need and
all the new skills that we need for the
global low-carbon transition
very briefly judy a quick thought of
what could have been in it was there a
big idea you think they missed
well i think the approach to
negotiations is a big one we've got to
collaborate as a world and kindness and
consideration for other countries is an
element that's missing we're constantly
talking about china's kind of demonized
polluter and and so on but
the aggregate pollution is because
there's billions of people there and the
per capita pollution is actually making
chinese we look at it for way down the
list and the uk rise right up the list
when you talk of historical things and
per capita and so so a generosity about
how we move forward together and finding
solutions together and of course not
such only expensive industrialized
solutions would really help the world